at the top of the hour we told you about
a California business owner called Juan
Damaris he was getting grilled on CNN
and CNN yesterday after he dared to say
he planned to reopen his barber shop
even if he was punished for it he was
lectured by someone with a guaranteed
income some airhead
now Damaris says he's already received a
cease and desist order from the state of
California but he's continuing forward
Barbara Wanda Maris joins us tonight
1 thanks so much for coming on so you've
received a cease and desist order from
the state of California what's your
reaction to that well it's actually from
the city of Vacaville they came in here
the cops came in here today and gave us
a cease and desist order from the city
of Vacaville and you know abide by it
definitely I'm not I'm gonna continue
working them because do you say open by
barbers gonna continue to work and
they're gonna continue to serve our
community what did you think and I'm not
just saying this because seeing it as
another channel but I was really struck
by the pompous lecture that you received
from one of their anchors yesterday
someone who will not be out of work when
you are out of work what did how did you
feel about that well you know overall
she definitely had a like she was
somehow better than me tone my I think
she does have a secure job her hair
looked amazing and I think she's not in
the same boat as I am maybe we're all in
the same storm together but we're
definitely not in the same boat
I have barbers that are living day to
day doing undercover garage cuts and
unsanitary position locations when when
we were here in California and on an arc
stop with a clean shop in town we follow
a lot of sanitary regulations yeah I
mean we're not all in the same boat that
is absolutely right so do you think that
Vacaville the authorities there will try
to prevent you from operating tomorrow
and do you expect customers
well we're fully booked we have us we
have a full staff and we're fully booked
everyone's still coming
everyone's being extra generous with you
know their pay and we're doing really
well we're happy to be back serving our
community for happy we're back serving
first responders like we always have and
we're just continue to do it do I expect
back bill to come and cite me absolutely
and they're going to you they've said
they're going to you know I think that
that there's no plan in place so I'm
just going to be the escape Hill for the
city III can't resist asking you I mean
they're trying to prevent you from
working is is the city of Vacaville
paying your mortgage while you're not
working are they helping my family eat
while you're not working absolutely not
you know what they're else is they're
not doing is they're not they're not
going to the building owners that where
we release our our space from they're
not going to PG&E they're not going to
the you know the water department of
their own City and then I just paid my
city back you know business license and
they didn't waive that for me either it
seems like there's little to no sympathy
everyone's following suit with whatever
the governor
besides JTA and listen they've had 45
days to get things back in order to
build up the PPP to build up the new
movies and and they still are talking
about us being in phase four and it
being obvious before we can make a
living again it's it's very confusing to
me that so many Americans are continuing
to pay their taxes after how they've
been treated by their government one
absolutely you know good luck tomorrow
it's great to see you thanks so much yes